so gambit you throw stuff yeah and then
you throw it yeah I throw it I truly
really hard yes I'm just gonna keep it
then as throws stuff which is what I had
dammit my question then is um what
happens if you run out of stuff ah but
there's always stuff to try there's
always yeah and I got great to have you
on the team that was tough because you
know this is a new deck and they're all
little slick you know you know throw
them a bunch yeah I understand what if
you run out of cards how about you know
professor it doesn't have to be the
playing card it can be any type of oh oh
you could throw a business card yeah
yeah you could do maybe a new no I own
ozz could you throw a Magic the
Gathering card it's quite fitting
baseball or any spa what about a
greeting card yeah it's a little thick
but you know I can look you could cool
yeah no no no without cards you're
garbage
I control other things you know like you
in my pocket I have some change you know
because I had a euro earlier I had a
lunch Oh
so if we were attacked by sentinels at
lunch perhaps you could have thrown the
here oh yeah yeah you can true a yarrow
by this stuff cuz the meats floppy
scatters the meat I'm sorry you're still
missing with me on you
indubitably are you hearing as we're
speaking how incredibly lame you are so
you're fired
no yes I am firing you because without
stuff you are worthless
what if we're attacked and we're not
inside of a 99-cent store or in the
paper plate aisle of a Target or perhaps
at some knick-knack flea market in New
Hampshire mm-hmm what then I got the
backup you know cuz I got the stuff you
remember me what the staff oh I didn't
look in the file you have a staff you
trained underneath the waterfall with
the staff did that uh mm-hmm
I trained up training on the States if
the x-men ever have a parade we'll put
you right at the top
you hold that staff you look like the
world's biggest blade fan do you
understand you look like you brought it
to lean on as you wait in line overnight
for the new Twilight book not movie
what are those gloves go fingerless or
go finger those are the choices
none of this cats is coming back to
Broadway [ __ ] here's some fingerless
for you suck on it okay I'm gonna go you
know it's it's not goodbye
gabbi's if we're ever attacked while
we're all playing inside of a ball pit I
will call you no now would you throw
yourself out I could melt you with my
mind
[Music]